Sound effects make movies movies… but there’s
a bit of sausage making going on here: sometimes
you’re better off not knowing where those
sounds originated.
So start banging your coconut shells together
as we gallop through the secrets behind some
of the most bizarre sound effects in recent
movie history.
Star Wars sound designer Ben Burtt is viewed
as a legend in movie production circles for
his sound effect creation methods — and
with four Oscars to his name on beloved productions
such as E.T. and the Indiana Jones series,
it's no surprise.
The next time you or one of your friends swings
an invisible lightsaber in an imaginary battle,
just remember who came up with that unique
swoosh noise.
"Not as clumsy or random as a blaster.
An elegant weapon, from a more civilized age."
Working on the 1977 space fantasy classic,
Burtt found an old film projector and blended
its sound with an old TV to create the distinctive
lightsaber noise.
"When they just sat there and idled it made
a wonderful humming sound, which would just
slowly change in pitch."
However, even a maestro like Burtt needed
a touch of luck, and the whirring element
of the lightsaber's sound was discovered completely
by accident.
He managed to capture the iconic sound by
thrusting a shotgun microphone back and forth
in front of a speaker.
The inventive sound designer for James Cameron's
$102 million masterpiece Terminator 2: Judgement
Day came up with some frugal and unusual methods
to make the film to sound as good as it looked.
The special effects for the film were spectacularly
groundbreaking and ate up a large portion
of the then-record budget.
This makes Gary Rydstrom's achievements with
the sound effects budget all the more impressive.
Amazingly, an everyday item played a key role
in completing one of the film's coolest scenes.
Robert Patrick's T-1000 is chasing John and
Sarah Connor through a mental asylum, but
a row of jail bars appear to block him.
But he's liquid metal, so he just goes right
through.
Rydstrom revealed that he came up with a very
cost-effective way to create the sound: he
turned a dog food can upside down and slowly
eased the congealed food out.
The quality of Rydstrom's methods was matched
only by his creativity, which yielded another
unexpected and comical money-saver for Terminator
2.
By submerging a microphone wrapped in a condom
into a thick flour-water mix and then blowing
Dust Off into it, he was able to create the
perfect sound for the T-1000's shape-shifting
abilities.
Beneath the mines of Moria lives the terrifying
fire demon known as the Balrog, which shows
up just in time to ruin the day for Frodo
and his friends in The Fellowship of the Ring.
The sound of that blood-chilling roar was
achieved by dragging a concrete block slowly
across a wooden floor while horses and donkeys
were layered in to fill out the sound.
It was the work of sound designer David Farmer,
who also created the sound of Moria orcs after
a visit to a marine mammal center.
He told Empire:
"It was the time of year they had lots of
baby elephant seals there.
[...] So we recorded ourselves scrambling
around wearing cleats for the movement, but
the major signature sound for them was the
elephant seal pups."
Dinosaurs have been extinct for thousands
of years, so obviously, no one really knows
what they sounded like.
No, not even the people who worked on Jurassic
Park.
Although the finished product sounds fitting
in Jurassic Park, it does make you wonder
how wrong film makers have gotten when it
comes to movies featuring prehistoric creatures.
In a 1995 documentary, director Steven Spielberg
told sound designer Gary Rydstrom to, quote,
"go make dinosaur sounds that didn't sound
like Godzilla or Rodan."
What's really fun to me sometimes is just
having something on a keyboard and performing
it giving it a try seeing how it works."
Rydstrom's approach was to find a creature
that scientists estimate existed close to
the time of dinosaurs: tortoises.
The shelled creatures did provide the right
sound bite, but how it came about was both
strange and unforeseen: Rydstrom sat around
for hours recording tortoises while they mated.
Does anyone know what a giant rolling boulder
sounds like as it bears down on you after
a booby trap in an ancient temple has been
triggered?
No, but Raiders of the Lost Ark sound designer
Ben Burtt managed to create a pretty convincing
approximation by using an old Honda Civic
on a gravel road.
"And we just coasted down this road, and as
the car accelerated in the sense of gathering
speed that ended up really being the basis
for the giant boulder"
To record the sound, Burtt had to hang out
the back window of the car with his boom mic
pointing down toward the tires.
Does that make him the Indiana Jones of sound
design?
Eh, maybe!
The webs that shoot from his wrists have saved
Spider-Man on many occasions, but how do you
decide on a sound for such an unusual tool?
Spider-Man director Sam Raimi had high standards
when it came to what he wanted, and sound
department veteran Charles Maynes did his
best to come up with something unique.
Initially there were failed experiments with
blow darts and chemical rockets before the
crack of a bullwhip got the whole process
started.
With the first layer down, the second came
from a very unexpected place: a feral cat
that Maynes himself rescued from the pound
who would attack him every time he tried to
feed her.
"And she would spit, and that spitting sound
was one of the principle components for the
actual shot."
It's honestly amazing that putting an angry
cat in the sound design worked out so well.
That decision could have gone horribly wrong.
"Oh No… no"